a superfan i'm leanna you Anna coming at
you alive because he cheese at comic-con
with the cast of DC's legends of
tomorrow hi guys how you doing I know
it's an early morning you're getting
your start so far so good yeah yeah it's
nice being here Friday is a little bit
less more calm less chaotic you guys
still have that energy going on right
now we've got to talk about the last
seasons of Legends you guys had quite a
fairytale fun-filled season take me back
to the last season there were so many
different elements going on what was
your favorite scene to film for me it
was punching Rebecca professor Stein's
puppy Katie how about it was it your
dancing scene that was really fun also
pretty fun to put the Supergirl outfit
on in like seeing Nick in the in arrows
outfit and him running around like just
pretending to be on and off screen to be
Stephen Amell Abed holding so many
moments I think I think some of the fun
most fun stuff because it was also the
most challenging was Rey becoming neuron
so in the transition episode where all
the physical comedy and physical work of
figuring that out was a lot of fun cool
one of my favorite things about legends
of tomorrow is that you guys have so
much meta fun on your show I'm not
talking about metahumans meta as in you
poke fun at yourselves a lot nothing is
off the table
when you get the scripts and you're
reading through them are you just game
for anything or do you ever have any
hesitations I think you have to be going
on this show you know jump the shark 35
times so I think they've proven
themselves
absolutely like we trust them now yeah
we do now it was the first time the
Vikings episode with Bebo where all of
us were like what is going yeah we're
like this is it like this our Korean
arrows we thought when I saw the giant
blue thing I thought okay this is a
career stop that's it all the Vikings
and they stopped it and all of a sudden
it just took off and that's when
basically Legends became this critical
little darling because you know we we
poked fun at ourselves and that's the I
think that's the genius
and now Devo is like an iconic okay I
mean he sells the show better than us
really they should probably be here
doing the energy shake I mean I did just
use a Bebo gift to say you guys are
coming so yeah pretty much I'm really
excited because Matt Ryan was gonna be
coming back this season to play
Constantine when he does get to come and
join you guys and have some fun on the
Waverider what's that like for you all
on set well first of all that's a
wonderful app so he brings so much he
has a lot of chunks and you know it's a
joy he's very funny very nice
Constantine characters is pretty great
and it is so iconic we're shooting a
scene and he he was like in that you
know that Constantine pose like he was
on his knees with the yeah the lighter
and it was like it just happened to that
and I was like oh my gosh like that's
the Constantine I was like you look like
the poster he's a great energy to have
around not only for the show but but
just on set you know he's quickly became
you know part of the team part of the
family and it's exciting one of my
favorite things about the show is seen
the evolution of Sarah and Ava they have
such a great on-screen chemistry
together what's it like forming that
bond with just off-screen what's your
favorite part about working with her we
I mean we clicked pretty quickly we did
chemistry reads even when they were
auditioning for that part and I was like
oh that's that's the girl like hands
down
she's a phenomenal actress and we yeah
we hang out a lot so we have a lot of
fun if both have a lot to hogs I mean
yeah it's she's she's amazing
it is such a fun set for you guys how do
you guys like to pass the time when
you're not having to chase after you
know what that was true that was true in
season one and two and it was stress
very stressful and very crazy on set
when we're on said no now when we go
back to the to our greenroom cast area
but but on set we you know stressed out
because it was such a big show and we
hadn't figured out how to make it work
on set every day but these days well
trying to take the piss out of each
other oh yeah come up with our own PR
because there was never we never had any
press so we were like let's make our
videos we literally mmm that magazine
what school so this we're doing each
party anyway anyway the you know timing
weekly thing and they got a little
Brandon you got Stephen Amell and you
got you know grant they're all Supergirl
and they gave us little Brandon little
asked them at the corner at the top of
the photo magazine but now cameras in
the government well et has always loved
you guys and we may be next season
yeah let's talk about the fact that the
most epic crossover that you guys have
ever attempted is coming up crisis on
Infinite Earths I know you guys can't
reveal too much but tell me what you can
reveal I'm gonna say we've we have no
idea of what is going to happen I just
know it's gonna be crazy
well I get to play I was gonna say new
news that just dropped tell us all about
it yes
very grateful to have the opportunity to
play four characters in the crossover
coming back to play Superman and and
Clark alongside Tyler I was doing a
fantastic job when Supergirl and to have
two two supermen on the screen at the
same time I think it'd be a lot of fun
and also have Adam and Ray Palmer around
for some fun - have you started talking
about what your costume is gonna look
like is it gonna be just like your
Superman costume from the movies right
well they just I can't tell you
everything so I'm gonna leave a little
bit of it'll look like Superman who
looked like Superman and I'm getting
back into Superman no shame
definitely everybody's got us
everybody's got a muscle suit we still
do our best to look good because you got
it you got to be prepared for the photo
shoot might happen and also you know to
feel like the guy inside they did have
him us I hadn't also see it back then
but I also did a lot of work
oh yeah oh yeah man you're you're a unit
you're like you were 240 pounds man have
you been missing the Cape yes yeah I've
had very specific talks about if the
Cape Cape changes it should still
somewhat be the same or have the same
one because there's certain you know
regality about the weight of it and if
it feels like just a regular cloth it's
then you don't have that affects the
movement and the change okay looking
ahead you guys have already done so many
outrageously amazing fun crazy things
unless of tomorrow what is still on your
personal bucket list what would you like
to see your characters take on I want to
see McCrory have a few more girlfriends
oh okay some love interest wasn't it
looking for in a lady not a three boob
monster
garima she needs to be a pocket man Kate
yeah but you um
dunce a lot this season there is
something new happening for Sarah that's
really exciting
just getting a superpower yeah all these
years I'm like what kind of superhero
anytime my friends like oh my god you
play super here on TV like what's your
power and I'm like well being an awesome
leader yeah so finally yeah like that
sounds super like I don't have one yet
so what is it gonna be well I can't tell
you you know I always am excited to to
have the Adam and his ability to shrink
and do cool things like that brought up
because I think you know loved season
last year as much as we did but we
didn't know we weren't always into
superhero suits as much I think that's
something so far anyway
in the first episode a lot more Adam and
that's fun and just keep pushing that
that forward and making use of that well
thank you guys so much for joining us
I'm gonna get these superheroes into our
super ichi photo booth and you guys can
see it on all et social media pages so
thank you guys so much we'll talk to you
guys later bye
[Music]